was isst du dass der salat das ganze
jahr über anbauen kann es das machen
viele leute überhaupt nicht die pflanzen
den im frühling vielleicht noch mal im
sommer aber dass man salat auch im
winter ernten kann und zwar auch im
freiland das ist vielen leuten total
unbekannt das klappt auch nicht einfach
so man muss da zum beispiel auf die
sortenwahl achten in den salat ab und zu
ein bisschen schützen wenn es zu kalt
wird aber sonst ist das team nicht
einfach möglich und in diesem video
zeige ich dir genau wie das funktioniert
[Musik]
im gewächshaus und im frühbeet kasten
bauen wir im winter auch kopfsalat an
also salat wo man den ganzen kopf erntet
das machen wir im freiland also im
normalen draußen beet ein bisschen
anders da bauen wir nämlich pflücksalat
anders kann man aber mit normalem
salatsaatgut einfach machen also man
braucht da kein glück salatsaatgut zu
kaufen
man kann pflücksalat aus allen normalen
salatsorten oder salat samen ziehen ich
würde dir trotzdem dazu raten auch auf
die sorte zu achten denn es gibt eine
sorte die super super frost hat ist die
ich dir sehr ans herz legen würde das
ist die sorte backe ich weiß ich habe
wahrscheinlich schon zehnmal auf diesem
kanal hier über diese sorte gesprochen
und ich weiß dass das saatgut sehr
schwer zu bekommen ist also wenn du das
saatgut einmal hast dann vermehren am
besten jahr für jahr in deinem garten
weiter dass es ganz einfach einfach ein
paar pflanzen blühen lassen und das sagt
dann einsammeln
für diejenigen von euch die jetzt kein
bug vielsagend bekommen er gibt es auch
anscheinend eine andere sorte mit der
das auch ganz gut klappt die aufseher
frost hat ist ist die winter marie die
habe ich dieses jahr auch zum ersten mal
angebaut und die ja da haben wir ganz
ganz viele von euch geschrieben dass es
mit der genau so gut klappt wie mit dem
bug also probiert das auf jeden fall mal
aus wenn ihr keinen baku saatgut bekommt
die sieht auch sehr ähnlich aus also
vielleicht sind die sorten sogar
miteinander verwandt ich weiß es nicht
auf jeden fall sollte das mit der winter
marie auch ganz gut funktionieren bei
pflücksalat endet man wie gesagt nicht
die köpfe sondern einzelne blätter das
heißt man schneidet den ungefähr 4 cm
über dem boden ab und dann diesen sehr
zarten jungen blattsalat und die
pflanzen können wieder austreiben und
nach wachsen das machen die auch im
winter die wachsen auch im winter weiter
wenn auch ein bisschen langsamer als in
den warmen monaten so dass man dann bis
in den mai oder juni hinein komplett den
eigenen salat nur noch von dem winter
werden kann da braucht man dann auch
keine anderen sätze mehr weil die immer
wieder nachwachsen und erst im juni juli
gehen die dann in die blüte so dass sie
zu bitter werden
und da braucht man dann wieder die
sommer setzte von schoss festeren
salaten wie zum beispiel der sorte pirat
die man auch wunderbar im sommer anbauen
kann aber sagen wir mal vom dezember bis
in den juni hinein kannst du von diesem
einen b
klettern salat das ist eine richtig
coole sache ich würde pro person im
haushalt ein bis zwei quadratmeter einen
planen also ungefähr anderthalb
quadratmeter bauen wir damit dass uns
gut reicht damit immer genug salat im
bett steht der auch nachwachsen kann und
man regelmässig ernten kann ohne dass es
irgendwie knapp wird in dem salat den
wir im winter ehrenden den sehe ich am
liebsten ja sagen wir ab ende august aus
bis in den oktober hinein also du kannst
auch im oktober noch wunderbar winter
satt sehen der muss ja nicht groß
wachsen also man seitdem sehr sehr dicht
ich streusel da die samen einfach nur
über das bild so dass da ein teppich
entsteht so dass die pflanzen dicht an
dicht wachsen weil die einzelne pflanze
ja sehr sehr klein ist und gar nicht so
viel platz braucht und wenn du den dann
direkt ins beet sees und es ist wichtig
dass du darauf achte ist dass der boden
für mehrere tage also bis du einige
pflanzen in deinem bett siehst also bis
da schon ein pflanzen teppich entstanden
ist wirklich feucht bleibt bei salat ein
licht kaymer ist das heißt du bewegst
die haben nicht mit erde umkreist die
einfach nur aus kannst du dann noch an
drücken auf den boden aber dann müssen
sie am licht bleiben also du kannst
maximal so ein bis zwei zentimeter erde
auf den samen aus bringen wenn du das
unbedingt möchtest ich mach das nicht
ich treue die einfach nur auf den boden
aus und da sind die sehr gefährdet
auszutrocknen da also wirklich darauf
achten im zweifel dreimal am tag gießen
wenn es wirklich heiß ist damit die
pflanzen aufgehen können du kannst den
salat natürlich auch im haus vorziehen
in dem fall weil wir so viele pflanzen
brauchen die so dicht im beet wachsen
würde ich dir das nicht empfehlen das
mache ich bei dem satz überhaupt nicht
also ich sehe den nur direkt ins beet
weil es viel zu aufwändig wäre bräuchte
ist so viele pflanzen um dein beet damit
zu bestücken und müsstest die kleinen
töpfchen quasi dicht an dicht in dein
bild pflanzen das würde nicht so viel
sinn ergeben da dauert es ein paar tage
bis die ersten grünen tupfer in deinem
bett schießt und dann werden die
pflanzen aufstehen macht ihr keine
sorgen wenn du am anfang ein paar lücken
in deinem bett sind es ganz normal am
ende winter wird es ein dichter salat
teppich seien von dem du einfach vier
zentimeter über dem boden nach bedarf
den salat
lernen kannst und wenn es mal frost gibt
dann ist es wichtig dass du deinen salat
schützt das kannst du mit einem
einfachen gärtner fliesst machen
ich setze da immer auf eine auf einem
sehr dickes fliesst man muss mich darauf
achten
dicker das vlies ist desto weniger licht
kommt durch und im winter geht sowieso
weniger licht als die pflanzen gerne
hätten
da muss man immer so ein bisschen
abwägen aber ich kann euch gerne
einfließt dass ich super gerne verwende
das die perfekte dicke hat was auch sie
eine sehr gute qualität hat und nicht
sofort reißt so dass man das auch
jahrelang wiederverwenden kann unten in
der video beschreibung verlinken wenn
ihr schauen wollt was ich da benutzer
ansonsten ist es wichtig dass man darauf
achtet ja wenn es richtig friert
generell sollte man dann sowieso keine
pflanzen ernten weil die dann zu hause
auftauen und matschig sind und man den
pflanzen dann auch schadet wenn man an
denen rummacht wer die pflanzen haben
ihre eigenen frostschutz mechanismen
aber wenn man dann hingeht und die
anstößt dann kriegen die probleme dann
kriegen selbst die frost harrten gemüse
im garten nicht nur der salat wirklich
ernsthafte schäden also wenn das ganze
gefahren ist dann nicht drangehen ja und
was ich manchmal für ein problem habe im
winter wenn ich das vlies verwende ist
dass die salate manchmal an dem vlies
festfrieren und dann irgendwie davon
kaputt gehen wenn man das dann auf deckt
auch wenn die wir schon wieder aufgetaut
sind deswegen ist es ganz klug wenn du
die wände kohl schutznetze auf stellst
auch so bögen über deinem salat aufbaus
elektroinstallations- und die verwenden
wir auf jeden fall super gerne gibt es
im baumarkt kannst du dir einfach kaufen
zu schneiden ist auch nicht teuer
da schlagen wir ein paar eisenstangen in
den boden so kleine dünne eisenstäbe die
in das rohr reinpassen
daraus kann man dann die ohren
befestigen so dass sie bogen bilden das
ist wirklich easy und dann kannst du
darüber deine fliesst aufspannen gut
beschweren da wird es auch in den
herbst- und winterstürme nicht wegfliegt
das ist noch ganz wichtig aber dann
haben deine pflanzen eben ein bisschen
abstand zu dem vlies und das friert
nicht so leicht an den blättern fest
dass es kein muss wir haben das auch
schon jahrelang ohne solche bögen hin
gekriegt aber es macht es einem schon
ein bisschen leichter wenn man das
festfrieren verhindern möchte ansonsten
gibt es auch noch einige andere coole
salate und auch andere gemüse wie zb
caro
und wenn man auf die richtige sorte
achtet die man jetzt im september auch
noch anbauen kann wenn ich das
interessiert dann wenn ich dir gerne da
oben das video und ich habe auch ein
video in planung über die aussaat im
oktober also wenn du im oktober auch
noch gemüse anbauen serien pflanzen
möchtest dann abonniere den kanal damit
du das video nicht verpasst denn das
geht anfang oktober hier auf dem kanal
online wenn ihr noch tipps habt für
sorten die man genauso wie back here
oder winter marie im winter anbauen und
ernten kann also die besonders fonds tat
sind dann sind glaube ich alle dankbar
wenn ihr das unten in die kommentare
schreibt ansonsten findet ihr da drüben
meine playlist zur selbstversorgung im
winter da findet ihr noch mehr tipps zum
winter anbau und auch zum haltbarmachen
der ernte damit man im winter immer noch
die sommer gemüse aus dem eigenen garten
essen kann oder da unten wenn euch das
video mehr interessiert vielleicht sehen
wir uns ja gleich da wieder ansonsten
bis nächsten samstag macht's gut